[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
the mother and partner of u.s capitol
police officer brian sicknick say
they will keep fighting for a january 6
commission
the pair were on capitol hill last week
to lobby for the independent panel
which senate republicans blocked on
friday they spoke with nicole killing
about the vote
who they blame for the outcome and how
they are still coping with officer
siknik's death
after that assault on the capitol he
texted me he says
i'm busy right now i can't talk and that
was the last i
you know i heard from him it was january
6th the final time gladys sicknick would
communicate with her son
after he was attacked with chemical
spray and collapsed
his longtime companion sandra garza got
the fateful call
to rush to the hospital did you get to
say goodbye
no i did not they would not let me back
to see brian
it was only then when the emergency
physician and the
charge nurse came out to tell me that
you know he was on a ventilator
and i knew i knew then that
he wasn't fine thinking of you for
nearly
five months consolation has come through
cards from complete strangers
just when you think that the cards stop
they start
coming again from all over the country
and the world
actually what does that mean to you
that there are good people in this world
last week they finally made the decision
to speak out going door to door on
capitol hill
to demand a bipartisan commission
investigate the capital attack
we want answers and nobody nobody has
the answers i mean even the people who
voted for this
bill they don't have any answers and
it's just
sad despite their best efforts the
motion is not
agreed to they watched as the senate
struck it down
six votes short i'm disgusted
that the republican senators
that decided to vote no it's a spit in
the face
to brian it's a spit in the face to all
the officers that were there that day
did it bother you that some senators
weren't even there
absolutely that's a dereliction of duty
but their frustration
doesn't solely lie with congress so
ultimately do you blame the former
president
yes i do and i was a
person who supporter supported donald
trump
brian was a supporter of his i mean even
on brian's twitter page
he had donald trump's personal plane in
the background as his background picture
you know he was still the president at
that time and he knew that brian
was you know devoted to him and he
did not once reach out to me to gladys
he didn't even send a letter of
condolences he did absolutely nothing
and so you know it's
it's very upsetting you know that he's
not
and i would meet with him actually i
would i would meet with him
what would you say to him i would ask
him i would say
you know why didn't you reach out to us
and i would ask him why he he failed all
law enforcement that day
you know he has an opportunity to turn
this around you know if he's really
gonna back the blue
then back it up with your actions he
just watched it on television like it
was a soap opera
i don't understand it how can you be so
uncaring
would you consider filing suit against
the former president
at this time i'm not interested in doing
that
do you think both sides are to blame for
making this so political
well i think in every party you know
there's going to be politics
for me this isn't about you know being a
republican or a democrat or
it's none of that it's about doing
what's right for the country
and doing right by brian what do you
think he would make of
everything that's happening right now
well brian was very
he was a gentle soul he really was and
he
he had a work ethic that was
unbelievable
and um but don't push him in a corner so
what what happened now i think he would
be appalled but
he says it will it'll get better and it
will
i'm sure and hopefully he
brian will have left the legacy that
will help our country
i want to point out that during our
interview mrs siknik was wearing her
son's shirt and both she
and sandra were wearing necklaces that
contain
brian's ashes they say that that is a
way to keep him close and
they are still looking for ways to carry
out his legacy but they have not given
up
on a january 6 commission and they say
they plan to keep meeting with lawmakers
including congresswoman liz cheney later
today
tony unimaginable grief they have that
mission for the january 6 commission
nicole powerful interview it is
breathtaking to hear
the sicknick family and his partner
sandra talk about going from supporting
president trump to wondering where are
you mr president in the aftermath of
this
yes say something to us i appreciate
them sharing their story and say look
for them it's not democrat or republican
it's pain and
i like the message let's just do right
by brian also something as simple as the
last text had said i'm busy right now i
can't talk
such an ordinary text that takes on such
a different meaning now that we know
what he was dealing with at that time
very sad heart goes out to both of them
all right nicole thank you very much